hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within -
we've got a lot in store for us today
and we've got a lot to do so let's get
into it
so last episode we kind of encountered a
horrible monstrosity that was this evil
laughing lady or maybe she wasn't evil
maybe she was totally fine she never
actually hurt me so I have no evidence
with which to point towards her being
actually evil all I have to say is that
I was scared
my pants were scared off of me and
everything was going wrong so we're in a
new safe house and we got a lot to do
but I don't know where this is gonna
lead me either go to the marrow
operations I don't know where the
operations is hi everybody welcome yes
so we got a lot to do we're in a new
safe house we're actually right here the
girl's voice is coming from over there
but there's a lot of other things
oh the marrow wait
oh the marrow wait of course the marrow
would be like the marrow of the bones of
the system they're talking about a
deeper level in what's in here hi yes so
if I go into there it's probably gonna
lead to over this area and then I'm
gonna have more than but I'm not gonna
go to that just yet I want I don't want
to go in the marrow I will soon ooh
I don't need my coffee but I'm gonna
take my coffee anyway because if there's
one thing Sebastian Castellanos needs on
an early morning it's a cup of joe to
keep him going through the day even if
it doesn't need to fill my bullet wounds
or anything slurp I mean I guess I guess
it's like all of this is in our mind
anyway so what like why couldn't a cup
of coffee I like I'm collecting brain
juice from everybody and I'm injecting
it directly into my skull I don't think
there's any limitation
all right okay okay I don't think
there's any limitation on what exactly
is going on here the number of
applicants received through the Mew
centers has surpassed that of the
medical testing front registration for
the mute registering the Meuse enters as
a tax-free religious institution as
increased revenue Oh which we've used to
render expansions to accommodate the
influx of new recruits mr. wallace's use
of neuro linguistic programming creates
recruits that are far more mentally
malleable and stable than previous stem
candidates mute Center recruits are also
willing to voluntarily cut off family
familial ties which eases the pressure
on Mobius operatives working in law
enforcement no more pesky
missing-persons reports to file it is my
recommendation that miu-san a
recruitment becomes the möbius standard
for all new citizens it has been a
resounding success so that answers the
question I had yesterday on why all
these people were coming out of nowhere
to go into a system where all their
nightmares can come true it's because it
was a religious front and they were
intentionally targeting people that were
more mentally malleable than before
which is a fascinating thing and I could
delve into that but I I feel like I
shouldn't so I'm gonna just leave that
at up to you guys to decide what that
means
alright I'm gonna go outside I'm gonna
get a few more of these things over here
because there are goodies hither and
dither and I gotta find them
I can take one of those and just lock a
door down okay so we got a lot of
enemies out here and we got a lot of the
knife ladies that somehow oh and you
what even are you some tells me that I
don't want to encounter you because you
look horrifying you look like just a
horrible pile of bone so I'm gonna go
towards the various items here that I
need
there's just shotgun shells over here
now that may not seem like a lot but
some somehow these houses have had more
in them that they seem because like that
that that horrible lady in the last one
if you didn't see the last episode and
you didn't see the scares that went
through with that lady go see it because
that was what dayal why didn't the hell
wouldn't you come from on beyond out of
bushes for me no no no no no no no no
okay
all right oops not ready yet I wasn't
prepared for that
alright let's see if I can do the sneak
corner yes yes I can get them if I go
right here oh yeah nope come on come on
Sebastian stick to that wall alright I'm
over here hey hey come on come on
alright fine then come back over here
please I'm begging you I'm begging you
please come over here hey lady
god damn it alright what I'm gonna do
I'm a bottle no too far for bottle oh
you'd be big back a douche over there
I look over there although I stab you
you may not think okay you're gonna run
around the corner sooo you're just
running laps I ran into a jogger that
was turned into a zombie at a random
point in her life alright fine then come
on down bring your bathing suits we're
gonna split supplies on the fire hydrant
I don't know why this is funny to me
I don't know why a lot of things in this
game are funny to me but they're in
unintentionally hilarious boom baby okay
got some supplies in here that's an
ominous noise no oh no no no no no no no
no
damnit
oh damn oh damn [ __ ] it's not
that you don't know it's that thing you
did you don't know you don't know that
it could be absolutely nothing I just
went into an abode this is a Shack this
isn't uh
this isn't even a house I'm hidden I'm
stealthy I don't have a bush but I got a
washing machine and that's just as good
okay no that makes no sense that makes
no sense why would you do that why would
they do that to me to me to me think you
can do that to me I don't even know who
I am
I can't even say my last name right I
think it's Castellanos when it's
Castellanos whatever we know that was oh
god damn it
where'd you oh I got a bush hey I'd be
sneaking from the bush actually no Abbi
I'm gonna post up against this wall I'm
gonna get him I'm gonna get him good
okay I got a bottle Montag did bottle
here oh no oh did you just got out of
ring to my bottle will you sack of poop
okay I'm gonna do this the old-fashioned
way
I'm gonna deliver soup in person nope
I'm not I'm not I'm not gonna deliver
soup okay that's what I call my knife
they're called the soup and I'm gonna
deliver it into their neck that's the
idea okay now you're in bottle range but
let me get in cover it no oh you've
heard that one danyoung Oh suspicious
isn't it why don't you come
creepy-crawly over here so I can give
you some soup you look a little sick
nothing better than chicken soup for
hurt your closer closer come on closer
oh oh it was suspicious enclosure oh
they're so close weird how that was give
give
likewise ah there we go soup delivery
you spilled your soup
your precious bloody super all right
that's one down
yes okay I love that ability that is a
good ability nope too far for soup okay
manual soup delivery I'm gonna bush
you can't possibly see oh yeah the bush
is noisy not good enough no I know no
face okay you know what yeah you deserve
this
okay you deserve a lot of misses
apparently no I
I'm a bad sailor I'm a bad I'm a bad I'm
just back I know I'm a hole honking a
heck of a lot of bad but at least I
didn't die I only wasted all that coffee
I drank what was I even doing
I always forget what I'm doing I just
have so much fun with this because the
thing about this game like I I love this
game it's so fun like I I'm not even
saying that like sorry sorry Sebastian I
didn't have your back you got a lift
with your lumbar you gotta give it a bit
more oomph on the uplift sorry about
that yeah but yeah this is so fun
because the first one was fun don't get
me wrong but something about the
gameplay and like the little bit of open
exploration like added on to this game
makes it really really interesting
because I know they draw a lot of
inspiration from Silent Hill
like that's obvious but there's so much
more here that just makes it mmm real
nice real nice okay so I'm full up on
everything I need to use a medical
syringe obviously but I'm gonna give
them more handgun bullets I'm never
gonna be able to fill up this satchel
that I got but beggars can't be choosers
we still have some all right let me use
my syringe that's the good stuff this
time I'm not gonna sneak wrongly where
was that
I'm close by oh yes right over here
house key let me Pat that corpse down
like that did you guys hear a sound
because I sure heard Sam oh that's not
good you don't see nothing oh you don't
see nothing oh we got fire guy over
there let me reload because I can't stab
fire guy or else suddenly I am also fire
guy but the fire is in my face
oh he's coming in he's not you wouldn't
think to open a door his hands full of
fire he can't possibly uh oh okay yeah
no I'm fine baby
oh very silent I can't know what he's
doing behind that oh come on
who's coming back hold that door it's a
little closer little closer I know you
got fire
come on you sack sack rabbit right well
that's glowy
I'm just gonna sneak out of here I'm
gonna go for this one because obviously
if I get the other one fire in my face
and that's not ideal anybody back come
back come back I got soup for you please
soup soup soup soup good soup good soup
excellent soup okay I think I just got a
nope
get up.get why didn't you get up okay
big old douche nozzle piece oh shoot
okay not so bad not so bad not so bad
it's not so bad pretty bad but not so
bad okay so we got the shotgun shells
which is gonna be good for us for the
long-term
ah why why you do that
[Music]
also this this is so creepy the fact
that this lady I don't know what like
causes her to come up out of nowhere
what triggers are she just she just
comes up out of nowhere at random I
could be wandering through any part of
this town
I'd like to imagine and suddenly she
appears that's such a cool thing oh I
was not secure at all yeah I don't like
that oh that's not good okay i'ma run
now it's so scary
alright anyway gotta carry on to what
we're supposed to be doing yeah I don't
know what just happened I don't know she
just appeared out of nowhere I did
nothing to her I was perfectly nice I
was just wandering around it and then
she appears out of nowhere
don't ask me what happened all right
what's under here probably a body
yep that's body come on oh come on oh
god I'm all the way back here did I even
make this [ __ ] that I wanted to make did
I even make my bullets I did okay
alright whatever god damn it I don't
even have my shotgun now side of a [ __ ]
alright we're just gonna go for it and
then we're gonna gun it out of here
alright die blam decked of Castellanos
needs shotgun chills that was not my
fault I knew I knew and it's the ad
thing like I smashed the ad in it don't
hit no work so it's not my fault
grunting so much you weirdo
move please I need to go through their
Sharia did I you can't say sure you did
mark you can't say that I said there's
probably a body and I was clearly mad
not my fault he's so sticky on these
walls oh that's perfect perfect for
double dose you came back for seconds do
bad we're out of soup oh you know I'm
here okay oh no you didn't know I here I
was here you guy could have gotten that
no you got okay well I'm gonna stomp you
I think oh no you're dead you're very
good okay I'll take that I'll try to
scoop the green juice out of the fire
you think green goop ain't flammable all
right get out here gotta go oh I gotta
use a syringe that was bold of me to go
into that without that okay here we go
why there was a perfectly good gap
that's Sebastian you crazy bastard I
can't believe you use it so wild all
right forget that car forget those
people forget everything over there
wait I'm gonna go into the house and I'm
gonna go into the marrow again I'm gonna
go deeper in there because there might
be another weapon or there might be some
other upgrades that I can access or
there might be some story bits either
way that's a good place to go before we
find the voice of the girl I'm gonna say
it before I go in there because who
knows what terror lies in the darkness
the answer is a lot of dares lie in the
darkness yes pop that on that okay cool
all right into the mirror we go into the
horrible horrible horrible mirror what
looks like it's LA
some sort of password but my plan some
sort of password with numbers and such
oh damn it I can't even get coffee fine
all right we're gonna go find out where
the girls voice is boring main quest
[ __ ] I go for the completionist
route when I play these games all right
so you I don't know what you is but I
don't like it
that is the opposite of good oh there's
a lot of you why where did you all come
from Wow what is that thing though this
place crawls oh my god there's so many
of you ah all right well I can pick them
off that is a fact
but I might be able to lure that one
closer if I just get that one and I hide
in this tree
I can't I can't get cover by him the
street I want to ambush I wanted a tree
ambush I want to do a bush ambush all
right fine you turn around turn around
it
oh damn it fast
oh geez this is feasting on a pile of
corpses over the new no stay away from
my bush no no no no no no no I'm in a
bush you can't see nothing that's right
Bush Bush defense no you have the fire
what am i doing I'm such an idiot
think I had fire what was I even
thinking the answer is I wasn't all
right so what I need to do I'm gonna be
tactical about my freakin poon delivery
here oh [ __ ] where'd you come from fire
back here
well they don't know where I am wow
that's amazing
holy crap
okay I'll take it it's not what I
expected but I'll take it
holy [ __ ] I can't believe that how big
not know the bush defends all apparently
go back to eatin buddy yeah there's a
feast waiting for you feast
yeah buddy all right well let's see if I
can sneak I think the other guy's gonna
see me before I sneak this guy oh oh oh
that's the opposite of good like why
can't I run what why am I out of stamina
aw don't like that oh why am I out of
stamina I okay all right I'll shoot you
then got that one who don't like that
don't like that whose doo doo doo doo
you I don't like you I'm on a box now
you can't defeat me I'm on a box you got
a weird shuffle you got a weird shuffle
who don't like that I think you drained
stampa oh oh don't like that at all
excuse me I'm in my safe place Oh No
thank you
all right you gone Jason's don't like
that like that at all so there's Bravo I
mean it probably killable just fine and
I should probably use my shotgun for
though
Oh oh you're so weird oh my god what are
you holy Frick why why the music don't
do the music if there's nothing to do
the music for it's like fast when it
wants to be and that's the worst kind of
creature there's a worse because I'm
fast never what I want to be okay but we
did kill a whole bunch of guys that's
good and I got a free axe out of that I
don't even know why I'm trying to kill
all these guys I just want the goop but
it's not even that much goo oh okay all
right let me just trip over the bodies
there real quick all right I'm pretty
sure the signals coming from that pit
stop up there so I'm just gonna bypass
the rest of them and I'm gonna go for it
because I ain't gonna deal with none of
that you're gonna deal with none of that
okay carrying on up a hill we go
Jesus Oh God stop making noises you
sound like you're crying in the course
of horrible baby tears I don't like it
okay all right gonna carry on I don't
think there's anything in front of me
good all right that thing definitely
must have drained stamina whenever yells
because I was not sprinting I was sneaks
no I excuse me what's going on over
there
there's something happening I have no
idea oh oh that was you okay we're fine
all right
hello I don't think you're Lily but
what what the heck
will Sebastian please I mean I'd like to
think that there could be any child in
this but I guess the MU Center
recruitment program may not be able to
hello are you here are you I got my gun
in time just in case you're not Lilly I
don't think it's Lilly I have a hundred
percent feeling that it's not with the
pitter-patter of little feet going down
the back of the kitchen I don't like
that at all it's okay it's me no I
didn't forget the axe I had I had an axe
I was full-on axe
I'm full of axes amazing looking right
at the solution who would have known it
would be so simple
detective Castellano some case gotta
push this thing out of the way and crawl
in I'm so smart right boy I got to crawl
on my belly through boy it takes a lot
of grunting to get through that hole no
one take that out of context weird all
right Willie
or it could have not have been Lilly and
maybe your memory is making you thought
maybe your memory is making you think
that's Lilly's doll because nothing's
actually real in this place you know how
that is you know how that works
you know how it's all in your mind nope
nope don't like this is bad
ah perfect movie oh my god she's in
trouble
uh-huh no word get around back see where
that window comes out okay all right
sure all right yeah see I don't think I
don't think that everything is as it
seems
something is weird here and something is
playing detective Castellanos for a fool
oh it's real quiet
I don't like that not bad that's bad
news bears
okay all right we're fine Oh detective
Castellanos coming outside hello anybody
nobody okay all right
I was just business for nothing who knew
that I could let my guard down in this
game so easily
who knew that I should practically take
all my clothes off and run naked
screaming through the streets all righty
really hmm
it's someone planting memories and ideas
in my head I wonder just hang in there
all right you got it
will do wait a minute wait that house
looks suspicious is that the house that
I went into and got spooked not hundreds
unsure but I think it's one of them at
least or at least is nearby okay so we
gotta get back in to do her no opposites
no don't do that please don't do don't
know I'm gonna pull out my shotgun I'm
gonna shoot you with a shotgun nope Oh
oh that's horrible
oh no oh my god no no no good come at me
you gonna move you move I don't like
that okay can I stop you stop stop stop
to finish
I didn't like that at all there's no way
to sneak up on those things oh no my
sneaking skills are gonna do me for
nothing I'm gonna be boner Road when I
got those fingers crawled through the
bushes okay what's smoking over here
Oh Lisa get these guys goddammit dogs
jabber dogs you everybody oh jeez pretty
much might as well be anyway
hey fire guy can you drop your fire on
your own face that'd be great then I can
pour soup on your corpse that's what I
that's what I prefer to do all right I
got some bullets yeah bullets are so
scarce in this one I really got to pick
my battles because if I waste too many
bullets on these other guys then I'm not
gonna have enough for anything else and
it's a good thing I went and got those
shotgun shells because those things are
a gurgle gurgle gurgle I don't need to
deal with the fire guy so you can go
bone yourself off into infinity and
beyond for all I care I want to go
I don't like no it's Castellanos you
talking about detective Castellanos in
this mysterious house that's using some
black goop all right I'm gonna go in you
I'm gonna regret the decision but foam
did somebody say my name
detective Castellanos here anybody this
looks a lot similar to the layout of the
house that I got spooked in before okay
there's a Manor over there it looks like
the Resident Evil 7 place over there
[Music]
okay
if you use weapon bar it's good stuff
all right good why is her gurney in here
is it for me am I the patient Detective
Sergeant Castellanos following the
events at Beacon mental hospital in
October 2014
department policy requires that you
undergo a mandatory psychological
evaluation please report to the
standards and trainings division to
schedule your fitness for duty
evaluation huh Sebastian there's nothing
to worry about just tick a few boxes
answer a few questions SOP whatever that
means okay yeah I don't trust that at
all because that tells me that when I
think the KCPD is all part of mobius is
like inner workings so there's nothing
really here that's safe for detective
Castellanos to see yeah what the hell is
that doing there hmm almost like you're
trapped in the simulation from the
beginning and all of this is to play
into your psyche you've been trapped
here for three years they've been poking
and prodding you for three years
that
oh no no I don't be oh oh no that's the
lamas so maybe that wasn't Jojo in the
last episode maybe that really was
detective Castellanos who was stuck also
why is the house turned a shade of
cerulean everybody Damon's
call gym news file 15 psychiatric
assessment of detective Sebastian
Castellanos while cleared of any
wrongdoing in the disappearance of a
detective Oda and junior detective
Kidman detective Castellano statement
about beacon mental hospital incident
has been vague in evasive initially
reluctant to speak to a mental health
specialist detective Castellanos
eventually opened up about what happened
that day it is my expert opinion that
he's suffering from paranoid delusions
the recent death of his daughter
combined with whatever happened to
beacon seems to a fractured his grip on
reality is my recommendation that
detective Castellanos the bottom half of
the paper has been torn off oh yeah we
submitted to Mobius testing
[Music]
who turn this faucet on we're in the
router Oh who's that was there someone
in front of me I thought I saw something
right there did you guys see something
did you see something
have you been paying attention you guys
watching my back cuz if you're not
watching my back then I don't know what
we're doing there there's something
stinking up a storm on the table I don't
think my guns gonna do me much good be
here but boom Oh detective Castellanos
didn't get his boom what am I gonna do
without my earth-shattering boom let's
just leading me in circles around this
place I mean obviously oh okay yeah yeah
sure disabuse me you're gonna put me
through shock therapy you could put
clamps on my nipples Oh cuz this is a
nipple clamp room oh no don't make me
forget hello detective I was I say you
cannot keep me here uh is that what I
wrote is that my blood oh there's
something gonna pimp your mommy I have
to tell when there's gonna be a circus
no slights okay we're good we're good
everybody keep your head on a swivel
it's important
something Bad's gonna happen during this
hallway hey look it's that thing that I
was talking about it's that bad thing
but you know what keeps me calm cool and
collected in situations like this this
sweet shirt that I got the holographic
makes my braveness meter go way up get
yours
Marga Bayern comm if there's one thing
that keeps me cool and collected on a
hot summer day when facing death and
destruction is have this sweet new shirt
available in white and black big print
and small pocket print as well all the
different styles to keep your head cool
calm and collected anyway that was a
sweet out of it was totally natural
let's see what this we got another side
there's only 11 slides I've been getting
good about this one there's so many
quick cuts of someone in a vest and I
know I'm wearing a vest but like jojo's
vest was very distinct white shirt black
vest and and just because everything's
desaturating American no wait I don't
have a bestie back I don't have a vest
on maybe maybe was Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe
Joe Joe Joe they've gotta mention him
they haven't even mentioned him in this
game yet why haven't they mentioned him
Jonah was my partner Toto was great Joe
doe didn't have the mental integrity to
defeat Beacon mental hospital and ruvik
but wait who's that let me that's me
isn't it this is me semi oh wait
semi
me let me that's me right that's me
cuz in my last in the last game me you
asked me me hello it's me
let me yeah it's me okay boo-boo
I had a vest in the last one too I
remember that bo detective [ __ ]
well I'm boned I don't know sir wool
well I didn't do that
never forget beacon mental hospital I
don't think I could if I tried maybe all
of this is just one big therapy session
Hey look more red goop this mysterious
red liquid hello detective Sebastian
Castellanos here what do you want no I
wonder why yeah funny about that
oh is it no but I know what I saw god I
hope it doesn't happen again it's bad
enough in here already I don't want to
have to relive the past over and over
it's bad mess with me can't get
distracted yeah it's almost like the
people who are part of stem bring the
evil that they have in their heads with
them like this because you're all
running through one central mind doesn't
mean that everybody doesn't bring a
little piece of evil in with them hence
that photographer guy like it's like the
matrix you know I guess the matrix isn't
real but like where is it like the
matrix is like if people don't accept
the reality than reality kind of bends
to their whim like that's why the people
were able to move faster and stuff like
that like they weren't able to
completely break the limits but you know
it was just really interesting it's it's
kind of similar or at least that's my
guess because if it's not then I don't
know what's going on and then
an idiot which is entirely possible
probably true but you know it's just
it's just fascinating like fascinating
course of actions that's happening in
here that's leading us up to be able to
conquer our fears while also at the same
time reliving them over and over and
over again and if people weren't ready
for it like the mentally malleable
people in here then they just kind of
would believe that everything in front
of them was happening as it was
happening and take everything at truth
you know what I mean
and so whatever if there were voices
whispering in their mind in this place
then then they would take it at face
value
why oh no lady Oh late are you forcing
me in this building oh no please don't
force me in this horrible building I
can't get in this building anyway oh no
you think I get like a surge of
adrenaline some point something was
chasing run real faster thank you don't
come here let me try that again
don't come near me la la lady don't come
near me I don't want none of that thank
you who's that
oh no Chad every teen are you all right
you're very clearly dead you ignored the
sign god I'm not getting away from her
oh wait never mind I just got away from
her
serendipity dude aah that is me okay
let's see uh get over here I think it's
somewhere back here is it this one
oh no close though can I get in here nah
some of these sounds I guess you just
can't get in
oh well works for me it was this tiny
shed it was it was his tiny sure try
this again
oh okay oh I'm supposed to I didn't know
I was opposed to move all right ooh
what's this then
my footprint Oh Oh funny we've got a
clue there's lots of step use happen
over here let's see what direction
you're going in
maybe she just went to the playground
it's her took a winding path around her
oh this is like blood boy I am like
entire head straight through the side of
the house well yeah it might not be
lilies I think we're good
where'd you go Lily don't run away well
eh I guess I could have gone for Lily
first and then it would have taken me
through all the areas that I like that I
would have gone for all the extra
materials anyway so I could have done
that whatever all right when he crapped
up some more bullets over here nah I'm
just gonna work an error over here don't
mind me he's got a lot of work to do
over here in the air all right
fire power I already got the critical
one I don't have another high grade
weapon part I could get more damage but
that's do I really need it I kind of
want to upgrade the shotgun now that I
know there's some evil monster but the
5% that that does nothing I think reload
time would be more effective for this
anyway oh yeah that's way better
Oh get that oh I got a hold each other
that's sorry I'm dumb I forgot that I
had to all be down all right
see firing right now can't do that ammo
capacity nope can't do that all right
how about this guy
um charge time explicit bolt well let's
just do the standard harpoon because
that's a big damage boosting if I can
just get people right through the head
then that's gonna be okay range
oh it's tiny okay 50 all right I'll save
it get more bullets and then I'm outie
give me I only have that much gunpowder
I gotta use my crossbow more but big
dumb dummy BAM okay where'd you go Lily
I really got to use my crossbow
just on the standard bolts if anything
boxes no that's not what I want boxing
okay thank you
sweet weapon parts sometimes completely
forget that I can bash open the boxes
you guys keep an eye out for boxes and
then yell at me like in cuckoo-cuckoo
rude incongruent to sleep that's not
work
I don't even know I was trying for a
word there but you do that thing that I
said that I did that you do when you see
a box and I don't see it you understand
me wink wonk okay cool we're on the same
page here all right where am I going
get right ahead somewhere in these
bushes ah Lily she is part of the family
I know the jogger
the jogger around here good God all
right I have a get around this corner oh
no I'm out of stamina coming after me
we're gonna lose you in a bush very easy
to do that these bushes they're so dense
[Applause]
all right lost it oh yeah but I am
standing in the middle of the light so
if he turned his head over here you
would probably see me oh that's not good
okay how about we have an encounter here
oh I thought a guy yeah
oh yeah I shouldn't waste them on these
little guys but satisfying like I had
500 goop in him do I think I almost have
enough for the next level of sneaking I
think I needed 8,500 but I'm not a
Harvison sure next time after I get
after I find Lily's footprints here oh
if I didn't have the light on 24/7
excuse you
I don't have the light on 24/7 I have it
on at the most inopportune times that's
when I have the light on don't you come
in here telling me that I'm an idiot
I tell me that I'm an idiot you all
right mm-hmm
Lala lady try to find her oh wait that's
that's completely uh those footprints
didn't match up you're gonna say that
right now she must be in that warehouse
Oh smart girl but there was also a clue
over here okay how do I get in there
though oh I didn't know I can get in
this bus hello do you have anything lady
shotgun shells those would be nice okay
never mind then all right I'm gonna go
in the warehouse know how wait why are
you banging on that
did you see me I couldn't tell if you
saw me or not oh you did okay
come over here and get you come on new
clothes so suspicious Oh surprise soup
ah but you didn't expect that alright
juice juice do I have like a syringe or
something that I just suck that all up
with that I do I bet I do I bet I do
so the guy who was thumping on the thing
ain't thumping no mo that's okay are you
going buddy I'm starting to get the
mechanics of like the sneaking because
you can oh geez
you can sprint from cover to cover if
you're really smart about it but I'm not
really smart about it so get in there
come around the corner please tell me
you're going around corner oh damn it I
hear another one
here oh you were coming here any food I
did not throw it that far
all right whatever this works out hey
get your head it specifically only your
head the head soup acts and goop oh good
no no no what are you talking about you
don't I don't know what you're talking
about
what my legs just do wait what in my
legs just oh I'm sorry I got I got
distracted by by Alec's being silly
Billy oh I'm in trouble here yeah they
gotta get a push burn my bush
hey guys but my bush II there's my bush
okay
hide just like Lily taught me
I'm the bush
come on over the waters are the soups
very warm hot over guys done
I don't being crazy over there come on
the waters soup oh the soup ease oh come
on guys you've been so shy about the
soup let's see if I can do it guys just
one just one yeah come on where's my aim
Oh where's my aiming come on just let me
aim fine whatever come on hide by the
body of chat every teen over here all
right so they're going back to their
things whenever they were doing the fun
they were having over there that's okay
because I didn't die
and that's the only thing that matters
in this endeavor all right I'm here
where'd you go with that mother one go
where the weather one go where the what
where where you water off do over here
who cares
bottle so sweet okay I think they're
right around this corner
Oh Oh like ah I was gonna ambush you
ah are you so fast are you so fast
no not that Oh didn't need it didn't
need that Oh God ambush ambush please
ambush em yes see there we go oh no oh
I'm allergic to soap okay not that good
oh just so much green gel and there's so
many axes around here I don't even need
the axes I've got my knife I'm ambushing
up a sewer
there's something else over there don't
know where like Hyrum I'm gonna go
around the corner I'm gonna try to stab
me up something good that's the smell of
zooms OOP oh they're on the other side
of the fence I think I'm okay oh maybe
they're just on the other side of this
box that's what I call a shipping
containers big box right not on accurate
so I got a guy coming up behind me on
the right I got that guy scouting out on
the roof that thing over there I don't
know if that's actually gonna affect
anything but he's up there good for him
he's up high he's really doing good in
life Oh
yeah you know what just forget him
because he's a scout but I don't know if
he's gonna pose that much of a danger
all right so let's just take care of
this last guy and find a way into the
warehouse and then we're gonna find
whoever this Lily person is hey whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa they want
my soup j'son's didn't know you what
wait whoa that guy's that guy's fee I
don't like that yeah get back honky
bouzouki yep no come on
no no switch there we go okay okay we're
good these guys coming out of nowhere
where'd that guy even come from
I had nothing behind me that could have
possibly been in there it's a harpoon in
the truck
what what are you guys talking about Oh
bullets that's the first time I found
bullets in the wild in ages geez all
right fine then and they're tearing up a
storm where did that person come from
oh the guy on top of the box he fell off
the box and he came after me when did he
see me that looks that looks incendiary
that looks very incendiary I have like
fire I guess I could blow it up but what
would be the purpose of it right shoot
it that's that never works that's movie
physics right oh I didn't expect it to
work honestly and truly I did not expect
that to work so I'm just as surprised as
you are the place I burned yeah the
place I lit on fire yep that's where
that was okay oh look at that in the sky
that's that's lovely okay all right then
no did I burn them good oh I might have
burned him good because there seemed to
be coop here I'll take that excuse me
I'll take that Oh notice this right
don't you don't hear a thing right
silent is the night all right well let's
have a little fun excursion here hey
guys I'm gonna get a surprise brain
sorry
let's see if I could need to finish them
up there we go stop okay Oh No oh boy
that's not what I was over time should
be screaming shouldn't be screaming so
much and I've wasted too much on that I
wish them the explosive bolt and bullets
which was not necessary not necessary at
all all right
hopefully hopefully that did the trick I
don't know if I did all right let me
search the compound a little more before
I move on now that it's empty I think
it's empty you see right there one there
was an unopened truck over here
excuse me oh there's oil on the ground
now that would've been incredibly
dangerous right so far so good
ooh oh thank you just three come on give
me more than that
only got four handgun bullets I could
before I go in here I'm near to a
workbench let me go to the workbench
I want to go to the work Bunch bench the
bunch bench let me go to this bench
bunch like bunch up some bullets out of
some benches I don't have them anymore
like I didn't get any more gunpowder
really that's the problem but I do have
goop juice so if I go to the safe house
I'm gonna put that in my brain and
that's gonna be that's gonna be good
enough I wonder if even the guy is still
there oh god they just respawn over and
over again I guess they would right it
would have to just to keep this place
vibrant and populated see I wonder I
wonder if I'm killing these things if
they ever actually stay dead like that's
the big question here do they stay dead
because it's just me stabbing them but
it like does that really kill them
because the whole death doesn't mean the
same thing you're like does that really
apply or am I just full of myself the
answer but let's put some stuff in our
brain you am i to question what death
means let's put some goop in my brain
and then we're gonna be good all right
first step first I've got these slides
of Eleni save
all right lube got that Blom oh I miss
boxes okay I'll go back for the boxes
there are some boxes that are
unbreakable though the ones with like
the the wooden reinforcement around the
corners those are actually unbreakable
so I don't know about that but we will
hello beautiful
Oh God who took this picture hey beacon
my life was getting off the track before
I went into that place being inside
Rubik head like that
Rubick I haven't been the same since
they tried to tell me it was all in my
mind but my mind couldn't have dreamt up
the things I saw in there yeah your pals
and Mobius didn't have any problem
putting you in danger today there are
times when I'm not sure I ever made it
out and now I'm in another stem I hope
you're right about that we're gonna get
out alive wait a minute are you in stab
do you still love Kidman I can't believe
lily is still alive the fire can't
believe it tell that to my brain tell
that to the nightmares I've been having
for years out of all the little girls in
the world why mind
don't believe any of that I refuse to
believe that yeah I still think that
Kidman might be Lilly Lilly was taken
long before I joined Mobius like oh poor
brain goop doing checked inside my mind
oh you're so sweet oh yeah but I think I
think that's it like I have no hard
evidence other than Kidman looks exactly
like Lily and there was that weird like
it I forget what it's called but it's
like just some goop for my brain please
and I think I have a key
yeah I got a key so which one do you
guys want me to pick which key would you
like oh I hope one of these boxes
contains an awesome new markiplier shirt
holographic print oh I don't know if
what though the white or the black or
the big print or the small print oh man
I don't know baby
oh yeah he's shotgun shells almost as
good guess I'll have to go to markiplier
come and get that digger man nothing
makes me feel better yes but you can't
avoid fighting forever whoa excuse me
excuse me lady
excuse you lady I'm gonna get my
sneaking skills up more than you could
ever imagine I can't I can't I just shut
up basically is all I'm saying
shut up it's not your business and I'm
gonna go and upgrade this I want the
grabby hands grab hands are cool but I
don't have enough of that
and I'm gonna save up for the super
ability it's gonna be super close the
distance
I just need 12000 for that and then I'm
good excuse me you you you take your
stop just stop don't also I'm gonna
increase the stamina gauge because I am
so tired of running out of stamina like
absolutely what I don't need it
recovery not stupid health and it's
stupid what else I got here
raise your pain threshold ah that's
that's useful I guess that is useful
I do get hit a lot alright but whatever
you'll have another key okay I've been
missing those but that's alright
okay thank you lady I've got so much
sneaking skills
alright let's get back out there I'm hit
this workbench real quick just to see
what I got I'll look at that stamina
gauge oh look at that stamina great uh
I've got nothing I've got basically
nothing so I got to go for mmm I just
got to go for the harpoon bolts that's
what I got to do because if I have those
those are just basic goodness and I can
get another medical syringe just in case
alright we're good we're good let's get
out of here
let's get out let's save and then we'll
skedaddle oh yeah come on led led yes
do they not account for people that save
as much as I save I saved like crazy
oh you're watching me in school a rule
breaker I like that that's good yeah
although you shouldn't listen to me I
technically dropped out of college when
I had one semester left to finish up a
five-year program but that's a long
story good that you guys probably
already know this whole reason why I
could have been an engineer and why that
haunts me to this day say love
all right who's all
look at my sneaking speed I'm so sneaky
and speedy you never know what's coming
for you here's a hint it's soup hot hot
soup directly into your brain they'll
never see this soup coming all right we
gotta get into this place because lily
is in trouble or Lulu is in trouble
because what I'm thinking is it time
also doesn't mean the same thing here
like time is all over the place I'm
getting radio signals from people in the
past
honestly who knows how long things have
been going on I may have been trapped in
here for three years it's been three
years since beacon hospital so who knows
if I haven't been in here for three
years or people have been in here for
what they think is life time when in
reality it's a long time but like who
knows it could be all over the place
all right this looks promising Lily Lily
oh that's not good yet yep indeed I'll
take the goop
free goop hey nice yoga pose sorry yet
die next to this goop could the same if
you came from upstairs I don't like
those I don't like those signals because
hey yah hoops sorry I was busy kicking
and I didn't even kick it properly
didn't even know that was possible that
I couldn't kick something completely
over don't like that okay I was trying
to get up on this thing here we go
yeah these boxes I can't cut through
these boxes so but I probably missed
some other boxes to just have to take my
aggression out on this yeah oh nevermind
kind of investigate it okay gosh he's
have got it the resourceful little girl
yeah she is
yes the finder yeah just gotta find her
she's been trapped in it daddy's a let
gun yep that's a leg okay all right
moving on Oh something like a knife
excuse me lamp sorry how to get through
here hey did I do that in the first game
now it's vaguely familiar but I don't
know if it just DejaVu thank you there's
somebody in here
I've got a lot of poon bolts that need
to be put into somebody's brain I didn't
know that was not me well you didn't see
nothing my sneaking skill is so good I'm
so speedy on the sneaky box go the Box
disappeared right fine then well I guess
if he if he didn't mind then it don't
bother me none either
well where did I go
hello what did you run off cuz you were
scared know you can be smashing up a
corpse it's ok bu actually don't be you
that's a horrible version of you be
somebody that's not that
num-num you didn't see nothing hey come
over here hey come on hey come over here
oh those boxes that's weird how that
happens a light off so you don't get
bothered by that won't come no why no
get under there you stupid bastard
what is annoying hello hello I keep I
keep mixing up like what the things are
oh well this is closer than I needed to
be I hit him with it I know I'm gonna go
in here now this is uh this is there's a
problem oh no oh no oh no your poor
sensitive groin is exposed to my harpoon
what am I gonna do oh this guy is
hilarious
I just want to keep him here in
perpetuity all right I'll let him go let
him be 11 reset where did I go it's so
strange
oh come on all right I'm gonna get
through this with sooner
yeah we gotta get him to turn around oh
wait be patient about this
where did it go I have no idea I can
smell soup but I don't see soup what's
going on here soup smells coming from
all right well I hope it's over here
it's a mystery it can't be solved the
puzzle of this guy is unbeatable
alright I've only tried this like god
damn it I don't know why I pop out like
a million miles out of the war well I'm
stuck ah the bottle mechanics could use
some work here alright you just get over
here so I can frickin sneaks nong khiaw
I'm gonna ambush the Frick out of you
Yeah right there we go cheese why is
that so difficult he only gave me 300
that was not worth all that trouble
oh man being a being a poor soup deliver
specialist it's hardened these trying
times very difficult man cannot live on
super loan it's a fact
actually maybe man can maybe you can
actually you probably could live a very
happy life on soup alone well I say
these people just happen to be dying on
soup alone shock bolt workbench file
here
seismic trigger event this afternoon
system checkup revealed disengagement of
the core sound recovered team for
preliminary Scout report filed at Mobius
HQ shortly before outside contact lost
core tracking unsuccessful minor
temporal displacement but no major
structural damage citizenry beginning to
make call center inquiries core still
offline minor fissures forming in City
Hall area citizenry remaining calm but
unease is growing losing atmospheric
control temperature drops in double
digits another seismic trigger City Hall
Fisher becoming critical separation
imitative core isn't restored
Moby's Alpha Team has arrived to aid
core in core search interesting
oh-oh high-grade weapon parts hell yeah
ok but I don't need to use them right
away
or do I
or do i or do i cuz if I do that then I
could upgrade that and I could get the
super critical that costs a lot but
might be worth it if I do that but I'm
gonna hold off because I don't even have
enough to get it anyway so there's no
point in even spending the money to do
it so let's just keep what we got all
right movin on movin on movin on gotta
move we gotta move we got a lot to do
everybody in the club gettin tipsy why
is it covered in blood why is there so
much blood in this place where this doll
is that seems bad welcome come on in hi
there here anywhere please be sure to
leave your doll behind oh god what have
you get out there oh no it's picture guy
yeah I don't trust that I'm not even
Lilly right now and I don't trust that
what was that you didn't scare me
loser him the murderer with the camera
and the son of a [ __ ] has my little
girl I was so close
damn it yeah calm down think you know
you can think in your head into this
communicator I need to find another way
everybody's already in their own head
not sure I can trust him but he wants
out of here as bad as I want to find
Lily everybody's already in their own
head O'Neil it's Sebastian then how can
they think of you Haley maybe wait is
that you do you think that would be a
thing like in a weird world the reason
everyone is thinking out loud is because
they're already in their own heads so in
their mind they are thinking in their
own head right what oh my brain hurts my
brain okay oh good more gunpowder okay
so I got everything I needed here is the
warehouse pretty much cleaned out am I
gonna meet an enemy on the way down
probably probably probably right I guess
at least something's gonna spook me
because it can't just be as easy as
walking out the front door I refuse to
believe that it might be that easy
okay goodbye I'm gonna walk you know I
knew it was gonna be that easy
that ain't good
well that is this that's picture guy
levels are bad hmm
awfully suspicious around here something
seems to be brown
[Music]
what is that heck is that this is a
light falling now no I don't trust it
it's obviously a trap I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna fall for it oh never mind I
fell for it what's at the end of the
hallway I don't like that like this
don't like this at all oh boy there's
another mobius member of always
great cool fun fresh happy great I know
you got something bad in store for me
you guys watch that way I'll watch this
way and if something's behind me then I
don't want to I don't want to smile for
you
I'd rather rather not smile for you is
the ideal I don't want to do that oh
come on
yeah I you know I kind of want no all
right yeah forget him he's nothing he's
nothing oh well I'm walking now and I'm
not I'm not doing this well not my
choice oh you good girl where is she
well that's not good
I'm good I'm gonna go ahead and say that
to all dogs oh god oh god what am I
going oh I'm running in I'm running back
in Oh Frick this Frick this and Frick
all of you oh no no no no no no I'm
crawling I'm crawling look growth
survival skills Oh God crawl
they know the technology of crawling
you did okay you better be dead come on
through the hole
or the other one go there's to take this
group gotta get this goop suite goop can
you help me fight one of them there's
two if I take one you take one is fair
right
would the other one go it was two of
them okay I'm gonna knock this down just
in case I don't have a bullet to light
it with but I got a shotgun shell so
maybe a stray bullet will hit it let me
soak my Tootsie's in some oil here so I
can get fire feet as I go up and kick
him in the shins
yeah they're a little bit like Wendigos
you know you're not wrong about that one
they are quite when to GUI I know
they're still out there
hey is that thing still in the sky no
goddamnit
there's still there I know they're still
there maybe I could have trapped him in
the warehouse and that would have been a
good way to take care of them but [ __ ]
oh there it is okay there he is
alright good thing I have my sneaking
skills if I can just get out of here I
don't need to fight him cuz they like
they may give a thousand brain goop I'm
into bush
you can't possibly detect me in my bush
I'm willing to bet that I can't knife
him and I'm not exactly willing to take
the chance to try you know what I mean
the problem is they've got heads in
their face and their ass so they can see
from both directions which is awfully
problematic when I'm trying to sneak
around them you don't get no soup that's
inconvenient that is incredibly
inconvenient so I have to kill these
things oh you're much closer than I own
Oh opponent opponent wait wait oh this
was lit on this soil hey burn baby burn
baby burn baby burn come on one more one
more I got more
you are you get oh I did something
correctly just weapon parts that's it I
guess those are valuable I don't know
how they translate to goop though I
really prefer a bunch of goop goop is my
preferred currency so that PayPal
painting through Pegu are you up on that
thing why do you people like to be up on
that thing
two-faced crawly back there's six faced
they've got six faces their ass instead
of three cheeks it's six faces two
cheeks two cheeks do people have two
cheeks or three cheeks on their button I
have no idea so there would be fire over
there there is a barrel inside if I do
lead them inside I could get that but I
don't have i need like one bullet these
guys can take care of this the
old-fashioned way by shooting them maybe
I don't know if that's the old-fashioned
way but I tried
what do you see wait you don't have a
face in your ass
sir we did what no yeah
are you yeah give me a good lucky okay
all right then
who knew yeah hope I can reach your Neil
this time hope so but maybe not oh boy
alright good good no but I know who has
her
and he's got powers like nothing else in
here I lost them great where's that how
the hell am I supposed to get up there
okay I'm on my way
I thank you thank you love you bye oh
boy
great good love these sighs blah no no I
wanna know how about no no no no no to
all of that no to all of the above
no no why why would you do that why
there's no point in that he's making me
aggravated it making me Agrabah okay
fine I just gotta get through here get
back to Liam
we'll be fine that's bad that's a bad
sound oh okay but I'd rather take this
path with a normal zombie and the other
path not normal zombie you know what I'm
saying
this place has a lot of bushes I get a
lot of soup where yeah somebody order
some soup in here I can't see [ __ ]
that's really close to me oh you were
fast holy [ __ ] was that oh that was oh
that was not a normal zombie that was uh
that was a lady oh that's a bumble which
is oh that's a bubble which is a bumble
which so I can I can do this
she sure loves to run that one crazy
runner oh I just got to take care of
this one that's all I gonna do you gonna
run back or what oh boy that's
moderately concerning one one two three
tickle my feet
forget it run run into the bushes and
hide Oh [ __ ] no no no I'm in bushes
bushes bushes you can't beat the bushes
the bushes are stronger than you the
bushes are stronger than you know you
can't beat my bush
I just can't beat my bush reload my
shotgun just in case
did golly getting closer to that next
level of sneak attack yoosh and here the
nurse was telling me that oh you need to
level up your combat skills what do you
call what I'm doing then I call it
combat I call me an expert at that said
combat these are breakable boxes noisy
boxes and they have nothing in them good
they're boxes down there that I can
break yes I don't know if I trust it but
I'm gonna try it anyway nothing god damn
it no all right let's try I think
there's a straight shot over there I
probably can just make the run for it
okay I think good I think it's clear I
think I can just go for always best to
run at the very last minute when I think
I'm safe
how was it how was Liam Oh potatoes safe
in here okay we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're good
Oh Liam oh hi Liam okay hello let me
yeah you know yeah sure okay is the
right word but yeah I made it
no tell me how to get to City Hall Union
was built with a sort of backstage area
so Moebius operatives could observe the
test subjects in secret these
passageways are still intact enough to
bypass the fissures in Union but chunks
of the city are floating in the air how
are their tunnels their passageways is
not tunnels when you go in and out of
them you're basically phase shifting we
call it the marrow it exists in a layer
separate from what you see that doesn't
make any sense
fortunately for you it doesn't have to
make sense it just has to work but it's
a maze down there you take the wrong
path you could end up on the other side
of town where's this Merrill that gets
me to City Hall I've already been here
who comes up with these ridiculous names
I'll mark the location of the port it's
in the north safe house looks like a
regular computer but it's not I'll give
you the password you need to activate it
that's what I needed I follow the market
to exit b2 okay I should take you
straight to City Hall you could have
told me this on my communicator you know
maybe so but I couldn't have given you
this the passageways are still intact
but the collapse of Union has caused
infrastructure issues my communicator
says the gas leak is blocking the path
to exit b2 you'd never make it through
alive without this oh you're such a
sweetie bleak huh thanks for saving the
worse for last o Neill
based on what we've seen so far I doubt
that it's the worst you'll encounter
right you're not helping you're not
helping
shut up Liam shut up on you I have had
enough of you I can't take any more of
this I'm going out of my mind here but
that was chapter that was Chapter three
done I'm doing good I'm doing way better
i fairly died on this entire session oh
I am actually out of time for this one
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna pick this up like I
said again tomorrow at 8 a.m. I'm gonna
get a sweet cup of coffee before I go
mmm that's the good stuff so thank you
everybody so much for watching I will be
back tomorrow 8 a.m. Pacific Standard
Time and also I've been keeping up with
regular a DM stream and noon videos
Pacific time so I'm glad to be back and
it's super fun to be making videos again
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye bye bye guys bye
goodbye